now I don't tend to think of myself as a
particularly hateful person but
something that I do hate is this heat
magazine if you know anything about
tabloids then you probably know that
British tabloids are horrible and as far
as I can tell heat two magazine is the
worst of the worst Britain is currently
in the middle of a general election
which means there's lots of politics
stuff on TV and the way that Heat have
decided to publicize themselves is by
starting off an advert like it's a
political ad and then suddenly BAM Heat
magazine appears and it says forget all
that boring stuff read heat magazine of
course don't think about pointless
things like who's going to be running
the country for the next four years no
let's think about interesting things
real important things like who's got the
best beach bod this summer so with that
in mind and let's take a look at some
celebrity news shall we to make that
clear that is what it says right there
celebrity news so let's have a look at a
story um Britney Spears
eats frozen yogurts that's a that's it
seriously breaking news miss piers
popped out for a frozen yogurt the other
day we hope the yogurt wasn't toxic is
what it says there come back next week
for some more Britney related puns
wasn't really a pun and there's a
picture to accompany this breaking news
a running theme in this magazine is to
have little get the look bubbles you two
could look like Charlotte Church if you
buy this vaguely similar dress to hers
which is fine you know I can understand
that if you want to be trendy but um
this magazine takes it as far as get the
look have a sandwich seriously I mean
you can't you can't make that up that is
a real thing in a real magazine this
week and gossip everybody Wow with two
double use you two could join the cast
of Jersey Shore that's right you two
could become famous for no reason other
than having a bit of a tan and being in
idiots got a section here on celebrity
makeup disasters you know people making
their own decisions about how they want
to look and them being bullied about it
by a magazine they have a section here
on top ten beach bodies of 2010 Katy
Perry is number one I'm sure she's
flattered to have that honor though
she's probably not as flattered by the
fact that someone's been hiding in a
back yard taking pictures of her from
afar but it is another very highbrow
section of this magazine we're actively
invites members of the public to stalk
celebrities and take pictures of them
one of the things I really love about
celebrities on Twitter is that it does a
lot to break down that barrier between
celebrities and normal people because
essentially celebrities are just normal
people which is also why I hate
just like this I mean here's firm cotton
just going to work could you imagine if
you were just going to work and someone
was just taking random pictures of you
so that's how tabloids in my country
treat celebrities frankly quite weird I
mean if you think about it these are
people who should be being celebrated
for their talents I mean celebrated
celebrity it's in the name so why are
they being stalks why are they being
ridiculed why they're being bullied and
yet for some reason people in this
country still want to try and be famous
and not just that I mean people want to
be celebrities just for the sake of
being celebrities a question that I get
asked every now and again and one that I
wanted to answer in this video is how do
I become YouTube famous how do I become
a YouTube celebrity in my opinion
YouTube is almost as detrimental to this
kind of wanting to become a celebrity
phenomenon as reality TV so at the same
time I love YouTube because it's given
me a platform to say to people if you
want to become famous don't my god don't
I mean a point that I can't have a home
hard enough is I mean seriously you want
to be treated like the people in these
magazines are treated are you sure
that's at the extreme end of this topic
but being famous shouldn't be top of
your agenda the reason that I make
youtube videos for stars is because it's
fun it's something I genuinely enjoy
doing my priority is trying to make
something that I'm proud of genuinely
proud of in my opinion that should be
the thing at the top of your mind how
can I make something to the best of my
ability and then if you do make
something that you're proud of and you
want to put it out into the world then
do and if people like it then that's
great but if they don't that doesn't
matter because your responsibility
should be towards trying to make
yourself famous your responsibility
should be towards yourself and trying to
make something that you yourself are
proud and that is all I have to say on
that soar so thank you for not buying
heat magazine because it's a letter I
went to wear cuz I'm family friendly bye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool and yes it is
a Carl Sagan t-shirt